I'm quite pessimistic about there being
any significant outcomes I I you know I
am expecting that my research will
continue climate change will not go away
and really we're looking at adapting to
kind of fairly business-as-usual
scenario i'd like to be proved wrong but
i'm fairly pessimistic well I'm not a
politician but the fundamental problem
is extracting fossil carbon from the
ground so if there was a way to stop or
minimize fossil carbon extraction oil
natural gas coal and that's what i would
do but i don't i don't see a politically
feasible way of doing that now I I don't
see a huge outpouring of political will
or upsurge in in the the ability of the
politicians to reach me and will I ever
change I don't know maybe it will look
at them I'm not a politician and I I
think it would be less than we want and
I hope there'll be some focus it sounds
like there might be some progress
towards it and there will be some
pledges hopefully I don't think I'll be
enough to do the two degrees and and
then they'll have to be discussion
afterwards about one of the two degree
target still meaning for whether you do
other things to try and supplement it I
think that I think the whole process the
whole climate negotiation and even the
science process is it's got huge inertia
because there's so many people involved
has been going on for decades there is
unlikely to be any massive change in the
way things go it will continue to plod
on and probably too slowly really to
solve the problem but what it does is it
keeps the issue in people's minds and
there will be some bright businessmen
out there they're thinking I've got an
idea guys I can make this work we can do
low carbon this and low-carbon that and
so do energy this and so loans you that
so I think it helps in that respect I no
longer think the international
negotiation is the thing or solve the
problem but it will help because it will
it will keep it in the media you're
keeping people's minds
it will see major people talking out
about it and that helps is that be
enough to solve the problem the idea
known on its own not its own so the
argument for it for international
agreement is that you kind of have a
level playing field so if someone does
the right thing or the thing that that
the global community wants then they
will somehow get reward and their do
belong thing that somehow get penalized
and that's what it's really about so
quite often businessmen who are
interested in in doing low-carbon
technologies say two governments please
just give us a little playing for which
means please incentive hasta to do this
and not not the wrong thing and that is
probably local I mean I'm but you see
evidence already of technology advancing
despite the lack of international
agreement you know in the solar cell
thing is a remarkable success story
selves are much more efficient than we
ever thought they'd get to be I was in
them in Palo Alto's in Silicon Valley
this last summer and the number of
electric cars is incredible then on the
road for carbon reasons they're on the
road because they're sexy technology but
who cares I mean basically it still
works as long as you're getting your
energy from solar power or whatever
renewable sources so there are there are
signs that technology is is is taken up
the challenge of it and business taking
on the Challenger just needs it just
needs for politics to catch up a bit and
to say well hold on me why don't we just
have an agreement here that means these
guys get more help at the moment you
know in the UK for example there's a
tendency for the opposite to be
happening and withdrawing subsidies from
renewables and going towards nuclear
which is is locom only in the very long
term so yeah you'd like to see some some
encouragement for the natural tendency
to innovate you know just want to push
in the right direction hopefully I don't
think we'll avoid two degrees but we we
can also work on adaptation technology
mean we might go to ride out the worst
parts of going beyond two degrees
hopefully not too much more than two
degrees and I do worry sometimes that we
are always looking to some political
leader to tell us how it will be done
and yet at the same time we also on the
whole don't respect our political
leaders like we used to so there's a
there's a kind of inconsistency here
between looking up for guidance and then
saying we don't believe the word you say